ils ont de 18 à 30 ans et leur univers
tourne autour de ces petits riens de
moscou à vladivostok leur contenu est
aussi étrange qu'il divertisse la
plupart du temps le français même quand
on se paie la tête du président de
petites fautes et yorick tout le boeuf
avec 30 millions de russes abonnés à tik
tok force de frappe est immense et en
pleine croissance
anar s'en sert elle pour publier des
capsules linguistiques ou elle traduit
de l'anglais ou russes des expressions
populaires et nous une once
elle sentit un des textes légers ou
éducatifs et dit qu'elle n'oserait
jamais publier quoi que ce soit qui
pourrait compromettre son contrat d'au
moins 1 500 est le retour au pays de
l'opposant à l'excès navale né au mois
de janvier aura été un moment décisif
des dizaines de milliers de vidéo
appelant à manifester ont inondé les
réseaux des élèves qui décrochent le
portrait de la demi-heure poutine à
l'école sont devenues un symbole et un
prétexte pour sévir contre les géants
étrangers d'internautes pas là
sauvé a obligé les dirigeants des
plateformes comme techtoc à supprimer
des messages est désormais coutume ici
sous peine d'amendé la blogueuse
christine hackmann sky a dit qu'elle
n'utilise même plus les mots clics comme
navales menées depuis qu'elle s'est
rendue compte que ces publications
disparaissait soudainement de son fils
d'actualités pays détenaient ces
applications qui était pour elle un
espace de liberté seront soumises à des
lois morales pour protéger la jeunesse
disait poutine au début du mois issus da
il s'emportait ainsi contre les tweeters
instagram et facebook qui ont tous
refusé se plier à la censure tels que
dicté par le kremlin
c'est déjà le cas de twitter que le
gouvernement menace de bloquer
complètement en russie ce les dirigeants
et fasse pas des milliers de messages et
en guise d'ultimatum roscommon à tort
qu'il agence qui patrouillent l'internet
ci a déjà commencé à ralentir l'accès
tout ce qui est photo tout ce qui est
vidéo se télécharge beaucoup plus
lentement
photo epa le plus populaire des réseaux
sociaux en russie mais qu'on s'en serve
comme terrain d'essai ça envoie un
message assez inquiétant 0,6 mio au
brookings
ivan chad dans ce livre c'est le protest
à poney games est une case au stade
l'avocat sarkis date bignone milite en
faveur des libertés numériques pour
sauver dit-il ce qu'il en reste en
russie car à la différence de la chine
le gouvernement russe a mis des années
avant d'essayer de contrôler le contenu
comme il le fait déjà pour la télévision
sans des chaînes complètement libre
comme youtube l'opposition n'aurait
aucune chance d'exister encore moins
d'influencer l'opinion publique avec des
enquêtes spectaculaires comme celle sur
le palais de poutine qui a été visionné
plus de 115 millions de fois depuis le
début de l'ère mais une loi adoptée en
2019 qui a pour but ultime de créer un
internet souverain permet désormais aux
régimes de contourner les fournisseurs
de bloquer du contenu et même de
débrancher décide quand bon lui s'en
sort et nabokov qui est producteur de
contenu pour des jeunes comme un art ne
tient rien pour acquis
mais il doute que ce soit dans l'intérêt
du kremlin de couper les russes de
l'internet mondial son chemin trois
prochains mois
dans just son show nate fox les éliminer
aurait des conséquences économiques
catastrophiques et mini tubes de renault
avait entre autres mais d'ici là les
autorités se faufile là où elles le
peuvent et salariés subtil par exemple
dès le 15 avril tous les téléphones
intelligents vendus en russie iphone et
android contiendront des applications
pré approuvés par le kremlin en première
page le gouvernement semble aussi avoir
trouvé preneur chez des jeunes stars de
tik tok qui reprennent des messages
identiques au mot près pour faire
l'apologie du kremlin mais nous ne
sommes pas dupes dit christine
si le kremlin a prouvé qu'il est capable
de chasser les jeunes de la rue avec
force privés d'internet libre
toute une génération qui a grandi avec
le téléphone dans la main s'annonce
périlleux même si la russie prétend en
avoir les moyens
[Musique]